a prep star in Pennsylvania originally
committed to playing football at Rutgers
and then he came to his senses and
decided to go play for a real football
school penn state after three years of
college football Berkeley ended the NFL
Draft and launched thousands of think
pieces on drafting running backs he's
known for his ability as a receiver and
blocker but failed to throw even a
single halfback option in his rookie
season
I'm just saying Odell Beckham threw two
touchdown passes last season please
welcome
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
c'est quand Berkeley joining us on
behalf of Old Spice all new fresher
collection featuring five new body
washes and real benefits forged by real
ingredients like moisturization and
exfoliation as well it's good good to
meet you say Quan how are you did you
think you were gonna get a nice
introduction there do you think we're
gonna talk about all the positives it's
like a rose tea room no I can't write I
did not expect that at all nice but the
positive stuff stuff oh you got me a
little bit okay but I'm treating you
like a rookie of course have to now who
aged you the mo what like what's the
worst hazing you got by the judge this
year to be honest I'm lucky I didn't
really get anything crazy whatsoever um
probably just say hey Brooke do this do
that but nothing like you know some guys
have to pay for a whole bill and a veces
wait wait wait wait so you're hazing
consisted of hey rook
yeah like like Eli told me one time like
are you gonna survive did you survive
that but somebody calling you hey yeah
yeah yeah
wow I think you are really mentally
strong yes you see the Demerol guys like
the Denver guys gotta cut the hair yeah
I got that feel bad for him so that's
why I say like I'm unfortunate I'm
blessed to have the best ad what did Eli
say to UM stuff like I remember one time
we had like we would have an argument he
was like if I say is this is this cuz
you're a rookie you got that wait why
were you arguing what I think of
something like something do it Easter it
was like it was the most random
conversation nothing
nothing do football nothing no actually
so I was saying something that something
coach said in the meeting and he was
like no coach had this and I was like no
coach said this and he was like listen
if I tell you if it's Easter go paint
some egg
that was like that was like the worst
the worst of my season and so like I
said some guys got to cut the hair get
left with bills you know you can't take
dinner like dinner bill you can't tell
weave when you travel you can't tell
vets your room number because when they
order to stay put so kind of finesse my
way and you know technically you're
still a rookie to the fourth game of the
regular season
oh I don't know that's how that's how
the vets treat it that's what they told
me so hopefully I don't give them any
ideas so hopefully I just stay safe
there did you ever speak up in the
huddle
yes what did you say um just stuff like
kind of motivational stuff like
obviously like say like for instance
we're in a red zone and when we're not
finishing the red zone but I we're here
we got fine way to finish it let's go
put in your mind right now what we're
gonna want online no one's stopping us
some good news let's do it right now I
stuff like that but you never said hey
give me the ball or um you know
obviously sometimes you know your
competitive side comes out and you want
the ball moments but I never really it's
a really I thing when I want to try to
speak I try to make it by the we think
so we can motivate each other because at
the end of day if you just got the
mindset that you're going to score you
can't do it and football it takes ten
people so you can't do by yourself so I
try to motivate we as a team and try to
push everyone including myself to take
it into level because I don't think Eli
would probably want to listen to too
many people in the huddle right it
strikes me as just hey shut up he does a
really good job of commanding huddle
which is have you been yelled at yeah
that no but
yell that in situations be like listen
you got understand the situation here we
can't be like one time was like get
Chicago and I bounced it and took my
one-on-one and got the first down but it
was a penalty and kind of pushed his
back out of Pilger position what I
could've probably just took it easy
three or four yard run kept this in
focal position so he was like cuz I
balanced it obviously if the flag didn't
happen or what that matter but he was
like you got to be aware when you bounce
stuff and you take a chance on Tom's you
know you find it react and a pool and
ref like all that so it's not like like
yeah like he's my parent but it's like
kind of just helping me out give me a
vice in knowing situation and
having awareness of the game anybody get
in your face defensive players no I'm
not telling you I've been lucky
I've been lucky now no one down my face
and yeah and I mean I wouldn't just let
my face too well but somebody might say
something whether you let them or not
but they don't mind in a game on my team
you know yeah first came here general
Ramsey
what's June is we got to you got he got
my face with that Jalen um you know
that's general Ramsey he's a heck of a
player a great trash talker and it
motivates them is part of his game but
what's he saying to you know in a moment
you lose though you're losing remember I
remember I've got what I'm saying but
you're going back out yeah you're going
back home you can't cuz like obviously
like especially the first game in the
year
rookie everyone is saying this by saying
that about you when you have won the
best defenders come at you and you back
down it's not a good start to ever see
them so obviously my mindset would just
try show him that yeah I'm here - I'm in
NFL just like you let's go at it and
like I said much respect to him he's
heckler could you take him in rot
running or that's tackling cuz every guy
if I had a run routes against him he's
probably the arguably the best corner
any game right now so I say probably got
to that but I 101 tackling I see you
know he gonna get something but I think
I'll get mine what if you got in the
Octagon with him I think oh wow now
we're taking over there yeah
I see he's long probably a good boxer I
got a little wrestling background on me
so um I think I think I can use that
tomorrow it's my van well once you get
him on on the ground then it's over yeah
I think so and I think probably a little
bit more to him so I think I'll go use
my strengths but you know I think I
don't know I've never seen them fight or
anything like that so maybe he's pretty
good but I think I'm going to always
take myself okay that's the right answer
let's go around the room on how much we
think sake one Barclay can bench I know
that you can go almost 700 squatting
right yeah okay
like 680 something like that anyway I'll
say 657 I do we didn't really do it one
for math okay my god I'm believing you
put on the bar and it's one rep let me
get it okay
quality I'll start with you a sake wine
is this all-time or currently or what
are we discussing this is a one like a
one-time how much you could bet max
bench right now a bench or in my best
ever your best ever
okay don't see anything okay 425
I like hell he's not she's got to try to
remember his max benchpress okay you
said 425 Paul yeah Seaton
I'm gonna go 375 oh he laughs it is I'm
gonna say 470 he was able to get a 470
McLovin I was gonna say two plates 225
but I go 500 that's a little too much
I'm gonna go I'm gonna go 465 I think
you do your research because that's a
good answer good that's probably that's
that's my best I could get 465 pounds
but just like Brady the great ones do
their research yeah exactly that's
really what this is all about but you
were small at one point where you didn't
even know if you could play foot you
know did your parents did mom say I
didn't want you to play football when
you were younger no wasn't that kind of
play football it was just that I was
losing confidence in myself you know but
where when did you get the thighs the
leg the calves always been not the cab
dies um I guess you know I kinda just
made up my mind when I was like 15 16 I
was like 155 pounds like this small
scrawny kid and I always had big calves
but I just say you know what I won't
play antenna for one day I won't play
college football day what's the best way
to do it my high school coach say hit
your button weight room and I just went
to weight room and worked and then for
some reason I kind of did it around the
same time I hit puberty I guess you
could say so I timed at the right time
and boom boom no 230 pounds and playing
on info okay go around the room how big
or shake one barclays thighs falling
32.5 32 and a half seat no Connor go 33
even 33 Fritzie 34 five all right
McLovin dower I can't be 34 inches
around I codon 21 I'm gonna go 27 oh
yeah that's like a waste I think
jeans and I'm like oh yeah weird 36 like
my waist is 36 mean when you said 34 I
think it's 28 27 20 yeah I think it's
Paulie go get a measuring tape will
measure allowed no no no I'm just going
now you were in journalism and I'm still
10 class right now okay
so what do you want to do with it this
maybe take your edge I want you know I
said to deshaun Watson I'm here all day
yeah yeah like I'm Jalen Ramsey you want
a piece of this you got to come hit some
yeah okay I just I just feel comfortable
um I like talking and a camera on a
camera on a mic and you know you can't
play football forever but you can talk
about forever okay the key is to do as
much as you can without interfering with
your career because once you start to
slip a little bit on the football field
then they're gonna go oh you spending
more time off the field when it cares
more but the more you can do just a
little bit and don't be afraid to ask
people questions now because you're
young yeah and I'm finding more and more
players are getting into it earlier so
when they do get out then they're ready
to go but I would apply for an
internship where do you live in the
offseason New Jersey okay I would try to
get an internship at some place you know
if it's in New York you could you know
just get in there get some reps to
understand what it's all about because
it's not just you wear a suit and tie
and you just start talking yeah you
gotta have something to say and get to
it and you may only have 30 seconds like
you think that it's nerve-wracking
getting the line of scrimmage and he
like calls the play and you've got a
process he just called an audible you've
got to process it if I'm talking in your
ear while you're talking on the air you
got to be ready to say something in 30
seconds so they may go no 15 seconds oh
no go a little bit longer go 60 seconds
they're gonna tell you these things in
your ear yeah so what you think is
complicated in football is not that
complicated when it comes to being in TV
but the guys who are really good like
Tony Romo makes it look easy it's not
that easy no but I'll get a job if you
can just a little bit get a taste of it
because you may not like it
you look good you got to be able to say
things that are interesting like what
can you tell me about being a running
back that I wouldn't know how do you put
me in your body to say you know what
this is what I see when I go to when I
see the hole I see this when you put
people in your world you know then then
then you're making a difference don't
tell me the obvious so if I say all
right what is Todd Gurley do best what
should I look for on Super Bowl Sunday
and I say you got 30 seconds his vision
the way he said was blocks now explain
vision so vision is what you see on the
field obviously as a running back and
the way defense is set up and their
schemes and how their own attack to you
so you've got to be one step ahead okay
this is what I would do if I'm if I'm
your producer I'm working with you I say
no no no what do you see or tell me a
story you know what and when I get the
ball I'm not even looking for the ball I
feel the ball but the first guy notice
is this guy and when I see him I go okay
I can make him miss then I pick up my
next guy
so what Gurley does is you get into the
hole quickly and then you got to make up
your mind am i taking somebody straight
on am i going left right like how do you
read a block how do you read a defender
then you're putting people in your world
I perspective in the way I see that tell
me what you what is it what does it feel
like to get hit hard are you telling me
now if you're on the air with me I'm
gonna say What's it feel like to get hit
hard like what's that feeling like when
you get hit well honestly you really
don't talk from my perspective you
really don't really notice it it don't
really like impact you at all you're so
focused in your journal weight it
doesn't hurt it really doesn't like
there's only a Lincoln mentioned
probably two hits in my lifetime that
hurt and it wasn't cuz of the hits cuz I
land on the ball it took went out of me
okay let's see I think that's
interesting because you I talked to
Jerome Bettis yesterday he said he could
hear defensive backs wince or cry when
they were tackling him I mean he was
like but could you imagine yeah he was
called the bus the bus for a reason like
you're going through the line and you
know as a defensive back you're going
this gonna hurt yeah I think honesty is
just also just the way by the way I
played a position you put yourself in
ways that you protect yourself so it's
not like football is not how was back in
the day way it would just blow your head
boom boom now if you lower your head you
get a fine for it so now you guys doing
smart ways where you protect yourself
but you also trying to be aggressive and
pick up yardage but I like that too
because you're like Barry Sanders never
got hit mmm the greatest he's he's
addicted
it's amazing what Barry's Barry Sanders
is underrated I believe yeah because I
don't think there's been a greater
Runner of the football than Barry
Sanders I'd say all the time I think
he's at best I like when you make the
argument who's the best running back you
talk about running but you got to talk
about everything blocking yeah okay we
talked about a guy who just had a ball
in his hand and it was just an x-factor
and could make people miss and get the
job done I don't I'm 9 minutes in a
running back position just any position
out in general I think it's Barry Simms
by far what's the funniest or strangest
thing Odell Beckham jr. is done with you
what's the funniest thing which changes
things on or off the field um I don't
know if I got any anything funny
exchange have you gonna do a club with
Odell Beckham we're 20 we're in our 20s
and we live in New York City so that
[ __ ] yes yes but I think he does a
really good job obviously everyone knows
who he is so it's like going out with
the football kardashian I wouldn't say
card - I don't know Kardashian
I wouldn't say Kardashian is right word
to use for Odell um but but famous yes
he's very fun but but unlike the
Kardashians he's accomplished something
wait wait what's that drop the mic hey
you said I thought I was paraphrasing
you got your old spice on you're
starting to sweat before this before
this I start I'm repping like a Old
Spice shirt and like I kid you not
without a handy bag ah deodorant I just
I'm back I'm right glad feel good again
I smell good nice nice how's your
daughter she's oh I made the biggest
blessing in my life she's nine months
right now
walking no not yet she's so close like
when I like when we stand it up I feel
like it looks like she's just wobbling
and she's want to take that step but
she's so scared and she just go back
down to crawling now she even crawl like
with one leg up like this like she's
just ready to go how much does she bench
I would say probably right now like
Ashley is funny to say like I'm like I'm
not lying like my friends and family can
testify for this like I hold her one day
you're gonna be something we're gonna be
one day so she's pretty not yet in the
better yet or push-ups at all but she
got sit ups down pack I like it but you
got to start with the core is that that
always were the course everything yeah
you shake one bark I'd love to have you
back if I can help you in any way with
this you know communication even coming
in to be an intern on our show for a day
when we're in New York I'd be more than
happy to you know help you and give you
ideas but I definitely appreciate it but
start on it now okay because it's
important to understand the business
it's so competitive out there you just
saw cam Jordan in the back this Saints
defensive player cams back there he's
he's getting ready to do this now yeah
you know he's close you know closer to
the end of his career but he's working
on being in the media start because it's
there's a really competitive and it also
help if you rush for 1,800 yards every
year - yeah
he's sick one Berkeley and joining us on
behalf of Old Spice all new fresher
collection and sometimes even puts it on
five new body washes real benefits
forged by real ingredients like
moisturization and exfoliation because
Old Spice knows that men have skin to
find out more at your retailers
including Target thanks for joining us
say Quan for more Dan Patrick show to
the audience Channel 239 on DirecTV or
download the Dan Patrick show app
[Music]